the biden administration's plan to begin
covet booster shoots neck booster shots
rather next week is being criticized by
the u.s and international experts two
outgoing fda officials and other
scientists told the lancet medical
journal that the widespread boosting
should be undertaken only if there is
clear evidence that it is appropriate
now the fda says in a statement that the
views of the authors do not represent
the views of this agency our doctor
david agus joins us to sort us all sort
this all out david this is why so many
people i think are confused and dare i
say frustrated and angry because even
the experts don't seem to be on the same
page what do you make of the mixed
messaging
i i think it's inappropriate for current
fda officials to write an op-ed based on
their ideas we need to look at the data
and you know the quest for certainty is
dangerous if you look at the data in
israel remember in july 30th israel
approved a booster shot to 60 and older
and there's more and more data coming
from that cohort in that country and
i've talked to health officials there
and it's clear that immunity goes down
on a monthly basis and giving a booster
shot raises immunity four to tenfold and
they are seeing fewer infections fewer
hospitalizations and fewer deaths in the
vaccinated who have been given a booster
shot so while there are risks associated
with waiting i want protection for
people in the united states
i want protection too and as soon as i'm
eligible i'm going to be first in line
to get the booster now these experts
also say that it's more beneficial to
vaccinate people who have not been
vaccinated rather than to boost the
immunity of people that have already
gotten the shot
well i mean they're right right we need
to vaccinate more people in the united
states i think what they're also
referring to is around the globe the
more we stop spread of cover 19 around
the globe the less chance of a variant
and obviously we're going to help many
many people there are more vaccines now
earlier in the pandemic there was a
significant
supply issue that supply issue is being
resolved now as the manufacturers are
making more and more doses and then
there's the argument that if we are
doing well in the united states our
economy is okay and we are actually
able to provide more doses to around the
globe and i think it's a cogent argument
i think we have to take care of our
country and then we can help other
countries with these vaccines because
where we need to stop this pandemic here
and abroad to stop the new variants from
coming on board
yeah i just wish people would pay
attention to the science it makes no
sense to me that the rates are going up
when we have vaccines more than one
vaccine to choose from thank you dr
david agus
thank you